all right this is the Tuesday evening
poster session and there are tons and
tons and tons and tons of posters right
here look look there's posters from all
the way back there and we'll dive into
them and we'll see what's happening and
we'll try to get some people to talk to
us and yeah get some Impressions maybe
we'll meet some people here and there
let's go
[Music]
now if you want to do a good poster the
best thing to do is definitely get like
a big poster don't put a lot of text on
it like the best posters they have like
one sentence that's really big and then
a few pictures and then maybe a little
bit of text not to criticize any of the
scientific work here don't just put tiny
tiny text and Tiny math on it like put
giant text on it and lots of pictures
and then people will come and then you
can still explain
stuff
hi doing a bit of reporting oh okay I
did work for a while in adversarial
robustness and so on what do you call
camouflaged adversarial patches Phoenix
okay yeah FL Pat is almost like what it
says in the tip right the adversarial
patches that have camouflage themselves
within the image so it's difficult for a
human to witness where the corruption
lies let alone an AI detection mod so we
see that in a lot of the state of the
artworks is they don't really consider
this visibility of theart as an issue
because they say they Lally corrupt in a
small area but a lot of defense
mechanisms that they've used kind of
detect that or just filter it out but
because it can be seen or it can be
detected by e so we're saying something
different we're saying we're going to
camouflage it within the image and so
these AI actually can't detect it and
our empirical studies show that what do
you what do you then call camouflaging
because usually the patches like usually
the distortions are so small in terms of
value that people argue you can't see it
yeah right see in adversarial patches
that's usually not the case actually the
Distortion is usually quite visible and
clean it's only the other kind of types
of adversarial examples that modify the
entire image that you might say are
canot be so in this sense we're only
actually modifying a small portion yeah
even though we're only modifying a small
portion of it we can even cause such a
small amount of modification and still
break the AI ESS okay and so highlights
the vulnerabilities that are still there
even in stateof the art Waters how do
you do that how do you do that yeah well
I'll be tell it no um how do we do that
well we kind of we follow an every Le
the AL the approach the attack
and that is BAS we start off you have
with a random patch see it's quite
obvious and quite clear what we do is we
try to optimize the location of that Pat
so find where the most vulnerable
location is within that image okay once
we kind of find that we say okay now
we're going to try and minimize the
visibility of that patch and so we are
kind of optimizing the characteristics
of these semi-transparent tool B such as
the size of them the color you know the
transparency the location of them within
the p and would kind of like optimize
all these characteristics until we get
to a point where our budget is is kind
of you know has been expired so in a
real world sense it be like you call in
the Google API Google say okay you up
all your credit or we get to a threshold
where we're like okay this cannot see
okay and how do you test that whether it
can be seen so in in our wayb we're just
using an L2 kind of condition so we have
a look you had a look at previous words
and usually we see like there's a
certain number of L2 distances where
okay that help that but what we do is we
just kind of exhaust the budget really
and say how camouflage can we get it
yeah and that's kind of OB then like if
you have a look at some of like kind of
the future directions this is kind of on
a digital level so some may kind of
argue that is this really realistic but
I like to think of it as like a step and
store say like it works on this case and
now they how look at the physical sense
so this is kind of a bit of work we look
working at in the future but the
preliminary results are showing that we
can kind of do the same thing you could
promote the algorithm to mod make noise
within the mask of the human so in this
sense it's just their clothing and still
avoid the AI detection this here is the
original image so this is the original
image this is like the this is like our
initialization so we completely cover
the the P the adversarial p and then we
and then that is after our attack or
after our optimization oh that's pretty
cool hey I'm doing a bit of recording
okay uh is it okay if I record yeah yeah
okay I have I have no clue of class
inent learning no not at all okay so
basically this is like a continual
learning where we have old classes and
we are slowly adding new classes yeah
and the objective is to learn the new
classes without forgetting the old
classes we are trying to solve an
Exemplar free continual learning so
Exemplar free is like we are not allowed
to store the training samples from the
old classes so at a time you have access
to the samples from the new classes only
and the objective is to learn new
classes and not forget the old classes
what is a realistic scenario where this
is because I can always just add a hard
dis you know and add and store my own so
the realistic so the realistic scenario
is like let's say you have a trained
model in Industry on a lot of your
customer data your customer wants to add
some new classes your customer wants to
add give you some new data so the
problem is like you you cannot go to the
customer and tell him I need all of your
old data so that I can train them
retrain the model with old and new data
so it's like you can add new knowledge
to the model by not forgetting the old
model so this is very relevant in our
industry as well as okay cool how do you
tackle this so basically what we are
trying to do is we are trying to use the
embedding feature space so what happens
is when we have deep neural networks we
learn very good representations of the
classes because of the nonlinear
activations we try to illustrate that
for all old and new classes we have a
very good spherical representations and
we can use ukian distance effectively in
this uh feature space but what happens
in continual learning is so this is a
high plasticity setting when we try to
learn the new classes very well and what
happens is we lose the feature
representations of the old classes in
the what happens in a high stability
setting is when we try to not forget the
old classes so we are unable to learn
the new classes well so this is a
problem uh the stability and plasticity
trade-off which is commonly studied in
continual learning and what we are
trying to say is instead of using ukan
distance which is commonly used in the
feature space we use the mahalanobis
distance so what the mahalanobis
distance why is it better because it
captures the distribution of the data in
the feature space so you assume it's a
ga yeah we assume it's a ga okay and so
we take the co variance metrics for each
class and we uh compar them out of his
distance can you say anything about the
fit like how well does a gaan actually
fit to these classes like you have some
quantifiable number that tells you if
that's even appropriate to do or not
Yeah so basically I don't have a
quantifiable number but it's like quite
common to you uh assume Gan repetion MH
so but as it turns out it's not so easy
to use malanov distance in the feature
space particularly because we are doing
an inverse operation of the Coan metrix
here and what turns out is like uh for
for example in lot of classes we do not
have a lot of training samples so let's
say 500 samples in Cipher 100 for each
class we cannot get a full rank Co
variance metrix because like for resonet
we have like 512 fure Dimension space so
we do a approximation over here so that
we get a full rank Matrix and we can
perform the inverse operation we use
this twoe transformation to make the
features more bsian we perform the
normalization of the Coan metrics from
different classes so that it's more
comparable in the distances okay so this
is what we are do and what we do is like
we train the model on the old class
class and then we freeze the model and
then we perform inference for all the
new classes for all the people were post
narrating this because the sound was
kind of terrible at the conference uh
so Nora is here with me uh and Nora what
what is the paper about that you're
showing us here so maybe in a nutshell
um we find that the inference results
you get might depend on the hardware
that you're actually using so inference
of what machine learning inference
generally right okay I see so I I
spotted a I spotted a piece of the
poster here and I was wondering you
mentioned this tiny tiny uh thing at the
back like the 7th decimal point why
would I care that this is different yeah
that's a good question well you might
not care if you're an a regular everyday
user um but for example if you're in
forensic um and and you then you might
care about it and one interesting thing
is what you can see here the second plot
is that we were able to craft samples um
so that they will be classified to um
one label on one machine and to a
different label on a different machine
so basically we just moved it outside of
the boundary or between the two bound
boundary boundary lines or this is
decision boundaries yeah so these are
specially crafted examples that you have
right here ex yeah exactly okay
and yeah why why do we even have this
these
mistakes so there's different reasons
for that and that depends on um the so
that okay yeah so there's different
reasons um so on CPUs for example in
general we have um floating Point
operations which are not associative
right so if you calculate a plus b and
then plus C you might get a different
result than calculating B plus C and and
then a and that is re relevant whenever
you change the aggre aggregation order
and aggregation order is changed in CPUs
for example if you're using SD
instructions or if you're using multiple
cores um and in this study we did it on
a large scale so we used um 75 on total
75 different platforms um and just
recorded oh yeah recorded the results or
the okay so what we did is we took 75
different
platforms and we this is actually here
I'm sorry the bottom FL yeah yes exactly
um exactly so 4 75 different platforms
we get a total of 26 distinct different
outputs um right so for these I think
64 um different CPUs that we used we got
I'm not
sure 16 different results yeah then on
gpus it's a different uh you have a
different cause um usually tpus are
accessed through accelerator libraries
and they support like multiple different
um convolution
algorithms and what they do is they run
bicro micro benchmarks for every layer
to to select the convolution algorithm
that that is the fastest at runtime so
there you also get different results
between different tpus and um the thing
is if you have two ution algorithms
which are approximately the same speed
and then it might depend on random
factors which is which one is actually
used so this is how we get the result in
the bottom plot um is that is for a
single GPU um and yeah we get so that
means we get different results even for
the S exact same GPU just for multiple
sessions I see and there's also aren't
gpus inherently somehow kind of random
in their computation a little bit is is
that I've heard this at some point that
even same GPU same
computation independent of this don't
they they have error correction built in
and then you can turn it off um yes yeah
exactly and for this okay so for this
specific questions um I'd refer you to
the to the main author and my colleague
which is Alexander schug and he'd be
happy to answer all your questions and
then you also because we talked about
this so maybe I'm not I don't care about
this last digit error at some point but
if the last digit error happens in an
early layer that might result in quite a
big error Downstream and you said you
discovered that yes this actually does
propagate across the layer and amplifies
itself yeah we we didn't really see that
um but also we didn't look for it um but
yes you're right it might happen in
earlier stages in earlier layers and
then the the arrow might propagate and
then you might get um higher confidences
for yeah okay yeah and what's the future
of this work what's
next um that's a good question now well
Alex actually I think Alex wants to um
to continue with this um with posits um
he has some some ideas on that um and
you don't I
don't was it tough to like you had to
actually go to the different hardware
and do all
especially for TP because it's just all
prop proprietary proprietary and so yeah
it's really hard to to find out about it
so what we did is we used the tlow
what's it called profiler M no not yeah
yeah Prof profiler to record which
convolution ARG I used and and it was
yeah it was uh it was quite a lot of
work but it was fun okay well very cool
so what's the lesson that people should
to take away here like what's the most
practical thing that people can take
away from this yeah
maybe be aware that it other to what we
expect inference is not uh deterministic
yeah exactly okay awesome thank you very
much you're welcome What's Your Name by
the way leing uh leing yeah so in this
paper we try to conservatively estimate
the value function of state so the value
function is like the classic value
function of reinforcement learning okay
yeah we try to learn some conservative V
function by a directory imposing panel
to on all these things and how we do
that so this is a first equation so
actually for the first time it's just
some standard buil update one and then
we can have like the second one and the
third one and for this one is L by AA so
for AR me here we are trying to AR me
the this the state value under this
distribution which which distribution is
this DS can be any distribution okay and
it's just a notation here but what D mu
as here D mu refer to the distribution
of the data set apply data set we are
actually trying to acing a minus here
actually we are trying to maximize the
value function of the St on in the data
so this is this is same and this two
equation is the same it's just
analytical solution of this equation
okay you have an analytical solution for
a conservative estimate of the state
vales yeah exactly and we use the
analytical solution to pull the B here
okay so for this problem actually we are
showing that the S May function behind
is here and the the better function we
estimate is actually the LA about the
true function here we have this all
about and then we come to our
methodology in this methodology for this
update is actually just equation one we
still use this one to l a v here okay
this just a practical implementation and
for this Q here we actually introduce a
new networ for Q because if you only
have V is actually really hard for you
to drive Ling yeah yeah and then we
introduce a q here for this Q the update
Target is actually the V here
conservative V yeah I here and if we
have V and Q actually we can do a and
for first time is just refer to another
classic method called Advantage we
reduction and you actually just use the
advantage to read the action so with
action with larger Advantage you just
give you more weight and this is the
first ter but I want to highlight the
second term the second ter we call you
bonus so in up saing it's trying to con
the action in terance the state of the
up data set however we're thinking can
we go one step outside of the DAT so
this is a second you can see we have
aring minus here aring minus is just AR
Max so we ar Max this time ARX and R
plus gamma B is just Q so we are
actually AR Max some Q Al that and this
is called bonus because it's actually a
little bit outside out of the uh
Institution for offl setting because in
onl setting we are we are trying to
learn some conservative thing but this
setting is a little bit exporation is a
bonus T what exactly would you get bonus
for you would get bonus for queue okay
you are axing a queue so you can get a
little bit bonus for policy for the
performance for your performance and how
to set this under them so in the upline
set is really help for you to set a
gravit because you cannot do online
action so how does they that actually
use the first time law to S Lambda this
is just a different Lambda and it's
corresponding scores here for example we
just take the first one then po if we
increase around a lot you can see the
first time loss just really really high
and the policy score score is just a
return of the Poli it's really slow this
means in the standard of awr deposit un
safe so we just select we can select
Lambda like 0.0 to 1.0 so we can say
this Lambda because this Lambda are most
are safer so that's the that's way how
we LDA and this LDA is the first one all
of the se but we can select it using the
LW and this two figures are just
performance comparison on some R stand
variation environments and the result is
that with the conservative estimation
you get better estimation yeah so your
performance is better
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah look this is pretty cool okay this
is pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
[Music]
oh